Rock and roll.
It really is a magical thing.
♪ (ROCK AND ROLL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This is it.
It's not just any hall of fame.
It's the fucking--
ALL: Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
(CROWD CHEERS)
Make some noise for my man,
LL Cool J.
I wanna thank all of you.
(YELLS) Mama, I made it!
DREW BARRYMORE:
Beauty and the Beat
blew the doors of my life off!
We love you and you will
always be in our hearts.
It's just unbelievable.
(MIMICS EXPLOSION)
Carole King is the
greatest songwriter of all time.
She's inspired us all so much.
Oh, thank you. Thank you.
(CROWD CHEERS)
Being Black in America.
It's not as easy as it looks.
(CROWD LAUGHS)
I went to
every single record company,
and you know
what they said, right?
"That shit is trash!"
I, for not one second,
changed my course.
Now that's rock and roll.
Tina Turner is who we're
here tonight to celebrate.
SIR PAUL MCCARTNEY:
This band is one of the greatest
rock and roll bands.
Thank you all very much
for hanging out with us.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES)
You're simply the best!